and now Tim Dylan is going to have
[Music]
we're live ladies and gentlemen welcome
to Tim builders going to hell my name is
Tim Dylan Devin cos is with us it's up
to him new co-host very high marks
people like him most most of them like
most yeah I don't know you know yes aim
well you know you got to earn their
respect I got her in the respect you got
to earn it reddit doesn't just give it
you got to earn I gotta earn you got to
work for it we're here we're on the
beautiful porch we're thinking about
doing a studio do we do a studio do we
stay on the porch I don't know does the
porch make us look like we can't afford
a studio I think people like the port I
know I don't know it's you know everyone
else has a studio people manage me there
like everybody else has a studio why
don't you have a studio and I can't give
them an answer to that and I'm like well
I like being on the porch yeah so way in
way in out their studio or porch should
we get a studio or should we do a push
should we show up fight Brendan Schaub
and Bryan Callen and then take over
their studio because we will do that
physically yeah I'm not talking about a
battle of wits I'm talking about we go
in their studio and fight them okay
really all right yeah okay yeah you
gonna send me first and then see how it
cuz we're gonna do a lot of the heavy
lifting up front throw me at them as the
Marines with you I'm gonna tactical
I will fall back I'm gonna judge your
progress and then assess what's going on
okay I believe this I think I would lose
a fight if me and Brendan Schaub fought
I would lose I think so yeah we lose I
think I would as well shoot you know
martial with their studio rah Theo would
be a little bit more of a fair fight but
he might still win mm-hmm because she's
got that southern yeah a wrestling Gator
yeah no yeah we're not gonna talk about
Geoffrey I've seen for the whole episode
we you know I know that people don't
like people a few people a lot of people
loved by the way some people love it
they don't want anything else
some people right now are in like hog
heaven with this story and they don't
want to talk about anything else they're
just [ __ ] in there happy they're
bringing it up and like family barbecues
hmm they're sitting there um but I get
that it gets a lot but it's just funny
to me it's funny too because a friend of
mine said to me recently said we got to
talk about other stuff you got and it's
like you know you have two presidents to
two American presidents that are eerily
close to a guy who's running an
international human trafficking ring and
people are like but you know what you
gotta talk about other stuff you can't
spend all your time it would be like
going to Thanksgiving dinner
your brother is being murdered in the
kitchen your sisters being raped in the
bathroom and you're like I get it but
can we have dessert I want to have pie I
like pie I just I don't understand so
then I had to explain to this friend why
it's bad that the president might be
involved with the human trafficking ring
you have to exploit you do have to
explain it to people yeah in this
country you do have to sit down and go
this is not good and here's why you
should care that we might be run by some
very very bad people you got to break it
down for them right it's not obvious
yeah - most people walking around why it
should affect them yeah why the the
abuse of children should affect that
they don't get it they're walking around
like I don't understand but what is
doing especially in LA everything's
about Sam likes about me it's about me
and my it's I want to just manifest the
life that I want right like I was
talking to somebody today Manhattan I'm
like it's getting bad and we're standing
in the middle Manhattan they're like no
I think it's like it's good dude things
aren't that bad I'm like we're in the
middle of the wealthiest city in the
country we're in the middle of it
outside of the city people are crawling
on the street they're living in tents
there knowing each other's flesh off
yeah just a few miles where people
it's fine I think you gotta relax but la
people who want to talk people do yoga
they want to eat avocado toast want to
talk about avocados and date it
everybody loves dating it's a lot of
dating podcast datings very complex and
interesting right because you don't
there's a certain type of woman out
there she's got a few pounds on she
lives in a major city
maybe she celebrates Hanukkah and this
type of woman has had a cushy life and
her only real challenge maybe other than
like dyslexia or something is finding a
guy to [ __ ] she wants a prince charming
to put his dick in her and they're gonna
have babies and her entire life from
when she [ __ ] gets wet for the first
time till she traps one of these poor
losers is about stalking and finding
this guy and she needs a podcasts about
it and it's everything it's Friday night
to go out Saturday night to go I think
I'll find the guy and I got him and then
Sunday they got and - why would they
like huh and then so there's gotta be
podcasts that break down every
millisecond of this interaction cuz it's
fascinating and uh and though that's
what really does well yeah it really
does well is if you can probe when do
you text do you text what are you taxed
when do you text what are you taxed when
you meet the Pat what's it like before
now people see me I'll [ __ ] you Tim you
are blow people in hotel rooms you get
prostitutes yeah yeah and so you don't
understand why dating is important you
don't give a [ __ ] about your family or
their approval you don't live a
wholesome lot yeah fine okay
correct Craig but still enough with the
dating all the time I get that I'm not I
understand that certain people need it
more than I do right I understand
trying to suck off some financially
desperate kid at NYU and then buy him
[ __ ] you know a fillet a salmon so I
can put my tongue in his ass is not I
get a lot of people are like oh that's
we don't we're in a different world like
we want to have
a good life okay but enough enough with
that you're in your mid-30s and you
can't find someone and you're enough
with that opposite I did that wick sad
about opposites how's it good as bad now
people don't really good as bad huh like
fat is now fin and I said that in the
which had the energy that used to come
with being thin now comes with being fat
mm-hmm
like when you were thin people used to
be like yes [ __ ] now no one will say
that if you're thin in order to get that
reaction you have to be three hunched
you have to be knocking on 300 pounds to
get people excited about you people like
yachts [ __ ] you go go you go girl used
to be a hot chick in a little black
dress walking around in 80s or 90s now
you go girl is a [ __ ] they got to
look like fanos you know you got to look
like fanos from the Avengers yeah if
you're a woman to get a yogurt fattest
then we've transferred all their
qualities from thin people to that's why
I have to lose weight because I don't
want to be part of the fat friend it's
not cool anymore that pride movement
it's happening I know I'm I'm abusing
myself they're like you're perfect like
no I hate myself and I want to die
they're like yeah it's [ __ ] no no this
is wrong and I'm killing myself I'm
wanting to kill myself no you're just
perfect the way you are there's no
relationship between weight and health
there is there is I can't breathe there
is a relationship I mean of course
there's a relationship all these women
you hear them these big big beasts and
they sit down they can't even breathe in
their life huh you're not my doctor
don't tell me what I should be like okay
I was first of all bagel guys following
me on Instagram unbelievable yeah that
was your reaction when you saw a baby
for the first time uh seems about right
how tall are you I'm 510 you're 510 yeah
now that is the height of most Hollywood
actors people
realize yeah like those Hollywood actors
are not six feet like I am although I
present much taller much most people go
you seem like you're more than six feet
you now because have a very domineering
physical presence uh but you were 510
yeah have you ever found that to be a
problem getting checks not really now
because you have kind of that LA skies
eNOS that women like yeah I guess so
yeah
yeah he looks like deformed he has like
a weirdly shame it's not a good
situation over there in Long Island with
bangle gosh
it's not good you're doing much better
you have that skater ish right slimeball
you know but la kinda huh you look like
you're like 12 still right have a beard
yeah like that's what I like people look
like they look like 15 year olds with
beards yes that's what they look like
that's that's what people that that's
what people in LA look like um
everybody's messaging me they're like
you gotta have on bagel guy and I'm like
do you do we bagel guy another calling a
bagel boss bagel boss okay because he
threw a fit now listen I gotta be honest
with you I have thrown fits in not that
bagel boss but they own a chain I have
had issues because there is no pride in
the service of others when someone comes
in and order something and you're
looking at a [ __ ] across on the
other side of the counter who could give
a [ __ ] less about you yeah and you're
coming in and all you want all you want
is a egg over-medium not sunny-side up
you dumb [ __ ] not fried to where the
yolk is now chalky over medium which is
a perfectly gelatinous where the egg
yolk is kind of like semen where it runs
a little bit down the down the roll but
not fully does it fall on the floor
it's viscous like like a like nice semen
but bagel bagel boss is you know people
like you gotta have this guy on and I'm
like do we really have to create the
world we're all gonna hate you know like
the world were in six months he has a
television show and I was like how did
this happen right it's like well how did
it happen because all you Fox but he
tapped into something with people
people there's a lot of men that are
angry that are not getting [ __ ] mm-hmm
they're not getting laid he's like a red
pill guy feels like well I think he
represents a lot of angry dudes out
there that are unhappy and you know he
kind of came out and he flipped out and
he got tackled by big guy at the end and
this is people like comment on it here's
the thing about long at that archetype
of guy is a guy that I've seen my whole
life a guy that will start the fight and
someone else finishes the fight that's a
very long I think Darya what are you
took the [ __ ]
that's his Long Island as you gather as
Long Island as you get as a guy
mid-sentence gets punched gray and then
will spend the next week twisting the
story so that somehow he's the victor
he's a good photo was six of them it's
like no you started a fight no one did
anything new you like and you got your
ass kicked but then people will kind of
twist to turn it but what people don't
realize about Long Island is of all the
pockets of white trash on planet Earth
right of all the collections of human
garbage that exists there is no
collection that is as charmless and that
has less redeeming qualities than the
ones that live on Long Island they are
not like folksy hill people they're not
charming backwoods Hicks they can't do
anything like you meet some trash maybe
or like feels from like in Louisiana
you're like well these people are
wrestling Gators right they aren't
living off the land or whatever
Long Island people are it's puzzling not
really a skill it's not a skill yeah
they're just lousy r disgusting the
actual word is just I was in Taco Bell
the other day I went to dinner at the
taco bell/pizza hut I have one family
member left my aunt Donna is the only
one I like she's hit my father his wife
are officially done after this weekend
they're officially done for while they
get nice I'll tell you what happened I
will go into this I want to talk about
first okay because a lot of people are
finding this this message of leave your
family and friends
incredibly inspiring literally people
are messaging me every day and they're
going oh you're the Gary Vee that I need
for my whole life I thought I had to
stay loyal to my family and friends you
do not leave them leave that and people
are waking up to this reality that like
you don't need these [ __ ] they're
ruining your life
they are their keep they don't want you
to succeed they don't want you to do
better than them especially if they're
boomers no group of people has ever
cared less about their children than
boomers nobody has ever been less
available for their kids they are a
deeply selfish group of people who've
raped planet Earth almost every problem
we have can be traced to mom and dad
boomer sitting on their fat asses
watching wheel of fortune while the
entire planet Amole eights mommy and
daddy
drinking wine on the phone with Aunt Sue
hi sell where's my kid I don't know
hanging himself in his room how are you
what's going on sue when you were
growing up you were always at somebody's
house and his mother was always on the
phone running her mouth with someone at
like these people who couldn't be less
present couldn't give a [ __ ] this was
not the era where we took the kids on
the college tour what college you want
to go to this was the era of TV you know
eating [ __ ] fast food KFC here's some
fried chicken and you're gonna watch
television with dad and mom okay so I'm
in talk about Pizza Hut so I wanted to
have dinner and my aunt otter drove me
there and she she doesn't wanna partake
so she's sitting in that car reading a
book and I said I'll just go in here and
have dinner by myself cuz I don't need
to dine with anyone else do you go out
alone every other girlfriend up do you
go out alone yeah I do it's very
empowering so it is it's very empowering
and if you're listening to this when I
tell myself and you haven't gone out
alone you're you're I used to go out
alone all the time and I would sit at a
bar and we get hammered and I would eat
and I would gorge myself with food and
I'd
back in my car and drive home plastered
and it's a good it you you you feel like
man I really own my life right I really
own my life control of your own desk I'm
in control you know and I was talking
about Pizza Hut and I said to myself
this is the last time I'm gonna have to
talk about pizza talk about I took you
Andrew Santino matter he's like dominoes
isn't good pizza is not gonna talk about
is not good I'm like number one shut the
[ __ ] up you Hollywood elitist you're an
elite I'm a man of the people
yeah okay yeah like George W Bush yeah
man of the people and the talk about
Peter what makes it so good you don't
have the man you'd ever talk about meat
side out here uh no they have Taco Bell
KFC is interesting that's an interesting
combo yeah that's wild yeah that's a
wild person big that does that mm-hmm
that does it Taco Bell KFC cuz that what
I like about the Pizza Hut combo and I
used to go red cup all the time you have
the warm cheesy gooey goodness of the
now they're not serving supreme pizzas
anymore cuz everyone's too lazy or
whatever to put the rhythm for the green
pepper on it it's a whole problem fine
fine
we could only do pepperoni nobody's
gonna do supreme fine you know I like to
supreme we get that little cardboard
mushroom it was never a mushroom and you
get like one of them yeah and then you
get a few green peppers you get like an
onion that was on something else you
know it was they just taken onion from
another thing and throw it on the pizza
but they can't do the soupy I was just I
was I was a devotee of the supreme and
sausage that is made from like meat bits
that they stir with water and make like
clumped up things hmm they don't have
that so I just got a regular cheese
what's nice about they talk about Pete's
how did you have the warm gooey pizza
and you dunk it in the marinara sauce
and then you have the cool refreshing
kind of healthy Taco Bell you know what
I mean like you have like a healthy you
do consider Taco Bell healthy when I
started with you very healthy um I will
have you killed I think it's very
healthy and I there it is the healthiest
fast food there's articles about it
thank you I'm not gonna have them on the
show but the reality is Taco Bell is a
very healthy alternative
okay especially for boomers who don't
want to raise your kids we ate that [ __ ]
all the time because my parents did not
cook they were too busy my father was
too busy playing guitar in one of our
spare rooms okay because he was it was
about him he was trying to get his song
his album together so we didn't cook
dinner he would go in and strum his
guitar and my mother would would you
know go take pills and teach swimming so
and I would just left to waste away in
my room and with no dog nobody got me a
dog oh okay well that's good well don't
hold your breath waiting for grandkids
how about that that's why I chose to
became a gay cocaine addict because of
the way that they reared me as a child I
hope they're proud of themselves how's
your album dad is it good
how's the song is it good so do you
enjoy it so it went from bagel boss do
you hated your dad it's got a connection
it's I've had enough with boomers lock
them up throw in a cake put the boomers
in the ice caps let the illegals in let
ms-13 in and get the Boomers whoo I'm
done with the Boomers now these [ __ ]
they're all gonna retire soon good light
them on fire
so I'll tell you why but I'm in talking
about pizza is my point I want to go
back to Bay there was there's a morbidly
obese woman with purple hair who is
costing the the cashier and she goes hey
hey and she's got another fat pig next
to her big fat pig with purple hair
another pig next to big beasts and I
walk up you know and now the whole
counter is is just a monument to bad
living and we're in the end it's a small
Mexican cashier she's sweet very
efficient a good Taco Bell cashier runs
about runs the bell she goes in the back
she's like [ __ ] you because that's
that's the job of it she's like let's go
you know and then you see everyone else
kind of afraid of her mm-hmm it's
usually a woman that can run it
you know yeah so this is this big a
purple haired ape is complaining that
there was sour cream on her burrito and
she requested that there would not be
sour cream on it and she's been a vegan
for a year almost a year and now this
has ruined her life because she ate sour
cream and she's complaining to a friend
she's going I've been a vegan for a year
I've been a vegan for you and I just
hate sour cream and I hate a lot of
exciting realize it was in the burrito
and she goes to the kitchen alright I'll
get you another burrito and then the
cashier walks away and this vegan lady
turns around and to a friend goes they
don't even care this restaurant doesn't
even care it's called a restaurant she
goes do they even care
so this fat vegan monster something out
of Monsters Inc is angry and she's like
I had a lot of it I didn't even know
that there was so I start so I don't
give a [ __ ] yeah I said where I go
between you and me it's it between you
me first bite first bite of the
seven-layer I've had a seven-layer first
bite of the seven-layer you tell me you
don't you know you don't taste the sour
cream when you go in she goes what said
I'm just asking so we all slip up yeah I
said I've given up dairy many times I'm
here right now with everything on it
cheese I get it be honest you go into
the seven-layer going to the seven-layer
you don't notice the sour cream you
ain't [ __ ] half the seven-layer the
[ __ ] ate half the seven-layer you don't
the cooling sensation is the sour cream
it's a separate thing everything else is
is is whatever but apparently they
whatever it is they got rid of the
cheese or the sour cream is worth
throwerw what's put [ __ ] her up my
point in that story is that if you take
a camera on Long Island and point it in
any direction and wait for 10 minutes
you will have a new viral garbage person
you will have a new viral Pig right okay
yeah not a lot would not
take a lot you just need to point it in
the direction of any human being
ordering something yeah if you go to any
place in Long Island where money is
exchanged and goods are delivered you
will find something out of Lord of the
Rings going crazy and I sat there and I
enjoyed it I enjoyed my meal in the Taco
Bell what you get what did I get I got
two supreme pizza with then I got a
chicken quesadilla and a a Baja chicken
Shalhoub that's the thing that's healthy
to you right the Baja well the gorditas
healthy the chulip is the fried bread
right the chili was a fresh good the
Baja chicken gordita I think is health
and you cross-examined a fat lady the
look well she's essentially she's lying
she's a fat woman who's trying to play a
game yeah and I wanted to let her know
that I knew I know what game you're
playing cuz her friend caught she would
have scarf down that whole burrito she's
not vegan know your ass you're vegan
shut up okay she's a fat medical biller
I don't know anything about it but I
guarantee she's a fat medical biller and
she sits in a [ __ ] office in an
industrial park in Commack all day and
harasses people who can't pay their
medical bills who are dying okay this is
what this okay and just like in a
biblical sense it will happen to her in
a few years she'll you know be wasting
away somewhere or she'll just have
exploded or whatever and that'll you
know she'll be getting the calls long
island here's the thing about long after
Hurricane sandy happened insurance
companies who are the devil like let's
be honest they paid out too much money
to certain like elderly couples so
people on Long Island certain Long
Island comedians were tell me they did
this were their job was to call up the
elderly people that now finally after
the hell of Sandy the hurricane had
ravaged their life they call the other
people it wasn't only elderly people I
think a lot of them were older people
their job was to call them up and
threaten them and go the insurance
company paid out 30 grand more than they
should have you owe us that money and if
not we're gonna take you to court
judgment on your house oh man and you
know how many people were willing to do
that Long Island thousands thousands
showed up for the job
thousands showed up for the job they go
we need you to browbeat elderly people
who just got back in their house it's
their first night in their new house
since the hurricane are you able to do
that and man they showed up in masse
they showed up in masks to call up the
greatest generation the world war two
generation should call them up and go
you always sturdy granted we're gonna
take that brand-new house from you
you'll be right in the street and they
would harass this is there is no more
morally bankrupt place yes in Long
Island is the wolf of Wall Street from
Long Island yeah yeah okay Long Island
deserves sandy was the very beginning of
the biblical reckoning was like the
locusts that long I long either deserves
10 of those things and the people that
are listening right now from there if
they have any self awareness they're
going yeah yup yes we do so let me tell
you about my father who now him his wife
have bought a second home in Long Island
they liked it so much they want more
property because it's good right
it was he get his money from he's no one
no failed musician right no one knows
and he's a wide salesman I guess he's
doing fine I do love my father hate my
father right people
listen to the show know he is a blah
blah blah blah but I he's part of a
generation that is responsible for
destroying civilization and he and I so
what am I gonna let him off the hook cuz
we're related
so I caught so he texted me photos all
him and his wife just bought a cottage
okay yeah white caps they just bought a
cottage and eat I'm not gonna say where
but wherever it is it's by the water you
know it's by the water but it's by the
Long Island Sound which is bath water
it's not the ocean Rocky Beach Long
Island Sound is for having a house on it
having a sailboat it's for a big mansion
at Sands Point
with a view of Manhattan snot to sit by
a beach whatever right fine him his wife
by a cottage they text me photos in this
cottage all the time look at the sun's
look at the sunset look at the sunset on
the beach look at the sunset on the
beach you know and all she talks about
when we have lunch is how bad it is for
like immigrants you know and then you
know right so I didn't go get the
cottage on the beach you know she she's
constantly talking about Trump and
fascism and get out the sunset look at
the sunset on them they invite me out to
see it like you got to come out and see
you gotta come see the cottage okay so
me and Ben fly out to New York to [ __ ]
Jeffrey Epstein's townhouse that was my
video can you imagine if Jeffrey F seems
like in his prison cell in the
Metropolitan Detention Center and like
his lawyer comes up to him they go we've
had an incident at the property and I've
seems like what's going on vigilantes
did somebody try to get in was there a
break-in they're like no you know the
fat guy that Rogan retweets he [ __ ]
your door and Jeffrey I've seen just
watching me like grind on his door [ __ ]
his door and after you just shaking his
head in that Metropolitan Detention
Center he's like where did it go wrong
where did it go wrong a few years ago I
was on my private island with prime
ministers and presidents and now some
fat guy with 60,000 followers who's been
shadow band
he's desecrating my 70 million dollar
mansion he's like this girl's
embarrassed like piglets happy because
this is so embezzle it'll egg penis that
he can only get hard when he shoves in
two ten-year-olds and he goes this is
mortifying this is really bad and he we
went to go see the prison man you could
talk now tell us about the prison
oh god Ben alright yeah we yeah we went
to the we wouldn't want to see El Chapo
why did I was gonna talk I'm sorry man
get route you ready now I'm ready yeah
okay okay it's not that complicated
baton that's not that hard alright you
feel like there's a lot of pressure now
it's a lot of nerves
people watching the show now I get it
it's very de we filmed the video which
was a lot of fun and then we went to go
see the prison that's holding El Chapo
and Jeffrey Epstein and what was that
like and there was someone in a window
right so in the lower window of the
facility some guy was looking through
the blinds why are you talking like that
you've never talked like ever I was
feeling down what he's like there's a
guy just talk like a regular party he's
like this is like what are you doing are
you are you putting on an application
for there was a guy in a well just talk
like you talk like a regular we go is
this fine yeah it's good so what
happened at the prison so there was some
guy scratching on the window with like
his fingernails just peering through the
blinds scratching all the way down the
creepiest thing a guy a crazy guy came
up to us yeah and he said this is the
last time you'll ever get to talk to me
it's true last time
right outside the Metropolitan Detention
probably some guy they just let out
[Laughter]
they're like go and start your life
security guard and we're like hey is uh
is Epstein in here he's like yeah no
[ __ ] Epstein's in here but yeah I'll
Chapo's in here and the guy said you got
a Chapo's here I don't know about that
Steve bought on you know a chapel [ __ ]
I'd love to put my mother-in-law in here
come on you know what I mean he's so
happy like we thought we're gonna get
shot in the face for going to the prison
this idiots so happy that someone's
coming up them yeah we got a Chapo
Epstein we got it all nobody comes here
they should come here cuz it's like uh
it pretty cool we got bars on the
windows that's why that's how to kick it
out we're like all right we thought he's
gonna be like get the [ __ ] out of here I
didn't even go near the thing I said
Christoph this kid Hootie helps us with
the YouTube channel I sent him so I'm
like if somebody needs to get a bullet
to the face it's this [ __ ] he's you know
what I mean although there is backed out
I got a free jeffrey signed that we just
did the video i'm like the last thing
i'm doing is walking up to the
Metropolitan Detention Center which is
like on par with Gitmo in terms of the
[ __ ] security measures I'm walking up
there
a little girl with a free Geoffrey side
I said I'm gonna get shot in the mouth
right now and no one will feel bad for
me no one will care
my father and his wife won't care they
were in a cottage they won't give a [ __ ]
so alright give the mic back to Devon
thank you thank you for your time I
don't know who was in the window I don't
know if it was a cell it's very
interesting because I read about the
prison and I think the real deal cells
are like on the inside
I don't think the people I don't think
you get a you know the view is City Hall
I don't know what do I know better right
people good message to me about the
inner work to the Metropolitan Detention
side on't really know okay I don't know
it was Takashi 6-9 yeah it could have
been could have been where is he
where's the guy thank yous and Rikers
actually yeah he's in Rikers how long's
he gonna be there uh I don't know I
don't know the sentencing I'm not sure
if it's happened yet I think he's you
know the trial is awaiting he's awaiting
the trial interesting no Rikers is do
you ever get worried about what you
would if you were in a prison or jail I
think about it yeah why because I love
crime shows you love crimes yeah I love
like people giving false confessions and
then their life is ruined
your friend could have what if I what if
you just confess I'm a jumpy guy you
know I could easily see myself just like
agree real quick emotion what the [ __ ]
they say and then just going to jail and
then I'm just raped for like 80 years do
you think you want to be raised do you
think maybe maybe it's a hot fantasy you
know maybe you want to [ __ ] it dude yeah
I like I just want to [ __ ] a really
built gang leader and I just don't know
how to do it I've never fought a gang
member
I've always had the fantasy of going up
to like the Bronx in a project and
[ __ ] like a real hard body gang
member
it is a murderer but that's never
happened pretty alpha yeah I don't want
to [ __ ] them I'd probably want to get by
them I feel like it's a waste to [ __ ]
them why is that I don't know I think if
they're a murderer they gotta you want
to see what they can win at the table
power of a murderer you know in like a
hot project gotta mean hot like sexy I
mean like literally hot and then like I
don't know I've always thought that that
would be a fun thing
never done it but does danger make you
horny or like if there's like I read of
like maybe this guy will bludgeon me
it's like almost I don't know I haven't
really thought this one out I haven't
really thought it through it's just one
of those things I think about him like
that's an interesting you know so my my
father who's gotta come to this cottage
so the day at when did I fly fly been
back Sunday and misses his flight
because he has Bojangles and falls
asleep in the airport like an idiot
he has Bojangles in North Korea he
misses his connecting flight not yet in
Charlotte he doesn't miss the flight he
should miss at 6:00 a.m. at LaGuardia
he's there for that he misses the
connecting flight because he eats
Bojangles and then goes to sleep in the
airport like an idiot okay like a fool
and then he runs over to them and
they're like are you Ben Avery he's like
yeah and they're like yeah we called you
a bunch and you know he's alright so
then his next flights like five hours
from now so then he goes back to
Bojangles and heats the second meal at
Bojangles in the Charlotte Airport and I
I call my father I go he's I'll I'll
I'll come out see the cottage today
because they've been very insistent that
I see this cottage which is 20 minutes
from the house that they own they're
trying to figure out if they can live in
a smaller space and then they may sell
the bigger house and then maybe get
something in Florida or whatever um he's
like okay well and this is after this is
we've had this plan for a while he goes
yeah well we're gonna go to our friends
house today that has a pool you're more
than welcome to come to that what hey
I'm almost on a train heading to Long
Island to come see your house I'm gonna
go to your friend I don't even know know
these people and I'm gonna go swim in
their [ __ ] pool and eat their food I
don't know them what but it's again this
is just a mentality of the Boomer it is
yeah sorry about that we're gonna we
don't worry who are you who are you my
only choice
yeah we have a very casual relationship
with someone that owns a pool we're
gonna go there we're gonna go there
sorry
don't worry about it we'll see you again
not a big deal this is no one has loved
their children last yeah then the
Bachelorette yeah
nobody has cared less who has been more
casual very Kash super cache is like you
know so the next day I call the next day
okay I call the actual next day and I'm
like okay maybe I'll come out today so
I'm leaving tomorrow and then he's like
yeah um and then they seem like I'll
loop her from the Train it's not a big
deal and then him and his wife start
arguing about that the uber will be too
expensive from the Train and that he
should just pick me up but it's becoming
an argument and you can hear it she's
like no you pick him up my desert guy
think he has a car my dad's like he's
got a car my dad invents a car that I
don't have my dad goes he'll drive here
they start fighting about it I'm like I
don't even love either of you I just
want to go swimming
I just want to swim I don't care what do
you think you two are great
conversationalist
I just want to come and swim so I'm just
like okay guys I can't do it I have a
meeting no worries no problems goodbye
they're done now they've been written
off they're done um we will review an
application uh next year to see them
potentially but the holidays I'm a free
agent for the holidays now except my
aunt I might go to my aunt we're gonna
do a Christmas thing in in Rhode Island
but I'm afraid of the holidays in Manila
I you know we're gonna put all the
archives up when we do the patreon you
guys can go to this episode called my
last Christmas where I detail why I was
no longer going to participate and my
stepmothers idea of a holiday which was
getting super market catered food and
eating it in sweatpants like a methadone
clinic and then doing the hokey-pokey
with a bunch of lobotomized relatives
that I have now so that is now over
eating macaroni and cheese that was
stirred by a heroin addict in a Long
Island supermarket okay while and then
they did the hokey-pokey at the end like
a bunch of them got off and they were
like did you know they weren't even
drunk our family party oh that's so
tragic
they weren't even drunk our family
parties used to be just debauchery and
drinking did you ever have like big
family parties yeah yeah there was
always a big political fight at the end
why it's like my mom's side of her
family's more Republican and my dad
sighs worked Democrat and they would and
your mom is [ __ ] plugged in yeah yeah
my mom wouldn't get involved is my mom
wasn't interested in this diaper that's
a great thing about being a conspiracy
person's you let the people fight they
ignore you one sides of taxes the other
side's like health care and you're just
like kids greater like mind control
factory farms of human beings they're
like like I have a joke now where's that
it's barely a joke where I go I go I
believe in lizard death cults you know
I'm I'm a centrist that's the centrist
I'm in the center I'm the despised
center now um but like an Irish family
we started off everybody was hammered
everybody was happy
my father had seven brothers and sisters
one of them died of melanoma young
everyone else was still alive a lot of
great music my grandfather had a big
beautiful home that he built himself a
lot of fun fistfights craziness whatever
great big meals we had 50 people at
Thanksgiving my nanny would have two 22
pound turkeys and a little bird it was
it was a massive thing I would go to
four or five a.m. and we grew up in that
we grew up in that world of debauchery
fun Reata k-- it was great was very
Irish family singing fighting whatever
food drinking now it's not as fun
because all of my relatives have been
divorced and all their kids are heroin
addicts so it's no longer its fun
anymore because the legacy of growing up
in that environment has been that you
can't leave your coat in a room
unattended because someone will go rifle
through it to go get a package now
they're doing good now my cousins
they're doing good now but I'm not I'm
not excluding myself by the way either I
had a rough time I used to steal I would
steal the family parties I would run I
run the pockets of an aunt or an uncle
and I probably still will but we were
bad kids and we grew up in that
environment where we like oh we should
be getting [ __ ] up and this is an
Irish family if you truly Irish you it's
great in the beginning and it has a lot
of promise and everybody's excited and
the kids are gonna take over the world
and they're all going to be Kennedys and
then like the Kennedys except the highs
aren't as high but the lows are pretty
low at the end of the Irish family it's
a disaster and people are divorced
people are broke
they're bankrupt they have multiple
addictions they're depressed mental
illness it's all bad so all very bets
the end of an Irish your your what what
are you race wise Italian and Lebanese
but not strongly Italian rich strong now
there's no real the heritage was like
Lebanese like we'd have you know hummus
and tabbouleh California kind of
steamrolls ethnicity Yeah right you just
don't you don't feel like it feels here
like you're just an American mutton and
you this culture is California culture
yeah right yeah there's no you don't
stick to anything yeah in the East Coast
people stand there little enclaves and
there and they was what everyone came
through these girls so they more like
they should you know absolutely yeah I
mean you know it is it is a tough family
I mean it's tough now when you were at
the family parties now and you're like
you know there's cousins that are like
some cousins are really brilliant
because one kid is brilliant but kind of
autistic maybe he's not autistic
he's like brilliant it's like very smart
he's gonna go to an Ivy but he like
doesn't say anything to anyone maybe
he's just disgusted by us you might just
be terrible
I think he's autistic I'm like I think
he's disgusted I think he's disgusted
that the most successful member of this
family is a gay clown I think he's a
little disgusted that that's the only
member of the family not currently under
like indictment
I think he's that's why he's not making
facial expressions because you
the facial expression he'd make is just
just crying he would just cry um and
then there's other cousins that are
friendly you know and then there's my
generation of cousins in there oh oh all
of us had our issues yeah all of us
you could tell though everyone's kind of
white knuckling like I just wish we
could just all go back to getting [ __ ]
up I think a lot of people are white
knuckling I think you know the damage of
certain life decisions doesn't
necessarily reverse itself this is what
people need to realize when you when you
make certain decisions and you go into
certain corners of the world you can
leave those corners of the world some of
those corners of the world stay with you
so there are people in the family and
not only cousins but older people
wherever where you know you know those
people and myself probably is or one of
them where you're like yeah we'll never
have the experience on the planet that
people had that were not involved in
some of those things you know like there
are people I meet and I ever there's
maybe I envy them because they've never
stolen money from their family a lot of
people have never stolen money from
their family I've stolen money you know
what I mean um a lot of people have
never uh invented a fake school trip I
printed up fake permission slips try to
get money to go to drugs
you know um cashed a fake check yeah I
ever do that
no have you done that no I heard heroin
addicts can do it though they don't like
what they need like a hundred bucks then
they just don't care about their - yeah
I never went there
I never went that to that part you know
but like there are there are things with
with with with uh with my family where I
go maybe that partying wasn't great for
all of us to grow up around some of it
was I mean listen there are people that
grew up because the next generation of
cousins didn't grow up with that they
didn't grow up with that we grew up with
that right so we internalize that as I
go that's the way to have fun so when we
all went out when we were 13 or 14 and
we could [ __ ] you know get booze or
drugs
we went out and we were like let's go do
it because we had grown up with the idea
that that was how to have fun that's how
you have fun I was just talking to a
friend of mine recently and I'm like
after 30 drinking looks bad it just
doesn't look great after the age of 30
it looks good again around 60 you know
it looks distinguished again in a bar
when you have a nice suit on you having
a nice cocktail whatever you know you're
on you know you've met a woman off a nap
who's 19 and she's trying to pay her
college loans you you know you're gonna
go eat her ass later and uh in a Hyatt
whatever it is yeah it's a distinguished
look it's a nice look yeah drinking
school at the start of life and at the
end yes the middle you're kind of seeing
you're like yeah look I just looking
[ __ ] up my bros and my [ __ ] xxx it
looks bad you look nervous every 30
year-old who's drinking looks nervous
and they should be because they realize
that life is passing them by everybody
thirty year old who's really drunk has
that energy of LaHaye man hey man folks
how are you
we've talked about Wix before we'll talk
about it again it's incredibly important
that all of you have a website even
though you know civilization is you know
potentially crumbling it's not a good
enough reason to not brand and market
yourself effectively sorry it's just not
it's just not it's selfish for you to
not have a website everyone else has a
website we're all playing by the same
set of rules we're all out here fighting
gnashing of teeth trying to grab a
little bit it's an attention economy
we're out here just [ __ ] [ __ ] the
void thrown out our thoughts and words
putting our content out trying to get
people grab people suck the blood out of
something you know we're trying to build
something here and you're [ __ ]
sitting around without a website because
you think social media is the only game
in town it's [ __ ] not dude there's a
bunch of guys that thought they're going
to
make it on vine you know where they are
now they're trying to do a check spot at
the Hollywood improv and they're living
in their car guy needs to be vine stars
so don't put too much [ __ ] effort
into tick-tock and tick-tock next year
is flip-flop and after that is something
called zukie or whatever it doesn't
necessarily have staying power but if
you have content you put it on a website
people can go and find it they can go
see it
instagrams gonna be all white chicks
buying jewelry within 8 months that's
all its gonna be ok Twitter's god only
knows what's going on with Twitter just
[ __ ] understand that websites matter
if you don't have the real money to get
you know somebody to do it for you it's
easy you can go to Wix Wix calm we built
a site Tim Dylan's going to hell calm t
IM dylan TI ll ons going to hell calm no
is just Tim Dylan's going to hell calm
go to that site look at the site that
was built go to all the way to the
bottom click on the link Wix will give
you 10% on any premium plan there's a
hundred and fifty million people who
have built their site using Wix if you
don't know how to build a site you can
use Wix ABI artificial design
intelligence answer a few simple
questions about you were your business
and which will create a stunning website
it's got an innovative drag-and-drop
design website builder it's very easy to
use there's over 500 stunning templates
do you have a website no why I just
didn't think I needed one you didn't
think you needed one are you embarrassed
about that now now I am good wix.com
folks incredibly easy to do you
understand what I mean no a lot of these
people you know you could get the
platform's right now like it is a dumb
thing I should put my own videos [ __ ]
away it can take your content away we're
gonna have a website we're gonna I'm
we're gonna be live a new website right
now being built all my videos are gonna
go on and everything so that you can't
just take away all of my content with
one fell swoop they can do that now they
don't give a [ __ ] okay so I'm telling
you it's very practical now very
important now to have a website if
you're doing anything creatively put
[ __ ] on the website as well don't rely
on social media you do not know what's
going to [ __ ] happen I bumped into a
kid in a comedy club recently that I
knew this kid was in a massive comedy
club openings a stand opened up in New
York you guys should go one of
best clubs blah blah blah I'm passing a
Comedy Store nap New York can literally
fob Bobby bomb I don't care I literally
without exception everyone that lives
there could burn in hell I don't care
9/11 everyday every building on the hour
I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] you you didn't
know what I [ __ ] you had when I lived
there I gave my best years to that
[ __ ] City it got very little the only
person I like is Patrick Milligan who's
from Long Island that is it who booked
the stand everybody else can burn and
[ __ ] hell I hope your skin melts off
your face the stand is good go to the
stand at the opening of the stand I have
a guy come up to me who is in the midst
of a fallen breakdown the guy this is
weird
comedy clubs in New York bring out
people the opening of a comedy club will
bring out people you thought quit right
and they just show up like they're gonna
like have the right conversation they're
gonna get back they're gonna get back in
the game they're like if I just bump
into the right guy things are gonna go
well if I just make the right quip and
Martin Norman laughs how are we gonna
turn around uh so some guy this guy's a
guy that I recommended for jfl like I've
been very nice this guy he shows up
right like hey man how's it been we're
standing outside of the club he goes huh
Suze Suze you hear that you know run you
got a run soon as you hear that you got
a run he goes oh ha I'm like oh no you
guys I'm ten years in I got nothing I'm
like well you're real funny guy man and
he goes don't say that don't say that he
goes I don't I don't look at you like
Greta these people do I'm not
starry-eyed when I look at you and I'm
like I don't think anyone looks at me
sorry I but whatever he's like he's like
you're crazy you're crazy I know you're
crazy
he's like so everything you sit like and
I'm like okay only in comedy are the
predict if you succeed on any level
you're crazy you're a lunatic it's a
people who've not figured out anything
that are somehow morally pure and good
yeah everyone else
to everyone else who's done anything is
crazy right so I say the guy I'm like
man you can't do this here you can't
have a breakdown in front of everyone
it's not that good he's like I have this
shitty job I have a day job I'm like man
at least you're connected without now
you're trying to find things so he
doesn't put a con in his mouth I'm like
at least you're connected to other
people at least have a schedule elected
to real people he goes like this he goes
I do it with other comics I'm like wow
yeah well and I'm like listen man you
know it is what it is but why are you
mad at me what do you mad at me for cuz
when I when I said to this guy a few
years ago he should do a podcast he
laughed in my face okay it is what it is
do it yeah
it is what it [ __ ] is man there's a
lot of angry people out there that had
an opportunity to to do the things that
a lot of us [ __ ] dead and why would
you not want to do a podcast [ __ ] fun
you know what I mean it's fun and you
should [ __ ] it you I just tested for
that David Spade show lights out on
Comedy Central I'll probably do panel on
that it's just fun why would you not
want to do it you just write jokes you
show up you make joke David Spade's
hilarious who give you know it's just
fun to do these are fun things to do
people you you can't not do things and
then get angry that you didn't get the
things that other people got from doing
the things you [ __ ] refuse to do so
but it's just funny to me that people
show up to a [ __ ] opening in mid
breakdown
mid panic attack thinking that
somebody's gonna be good over here
you're gonna work every night now I love
you come here never gonna go hug them
nobody gives a [ __ ] about you nobody
cares about you this is my problem I
don't have a problem with Gary
Vaynerchuk in the way that people think
I have a problem with him
I don't hate his hustle I don't whatever
do what you want to do the problem with
Gary Vaynerchuk is he never tells people
about their limitations he never tells
him to embrace any type of realism he
never tells him about the other side of
risk okay
he's he leaves all of that out it's all
about hustle and grind and all this
literal gibberish
there's better sales trainers Brian
Tracy Zig Ziglar they'll literally talk
about selling things and what to say at
every moment during a sale they actually
do that okay but the problem with Gary
music I'm all for you want to start your
own [ __ ] you want to do your own thing
I'm all for that I'm not now most of you
shouldn't most of you should not most of
you should not pull the car over and
listen to me if this isn't getting
through your [ __ ] head okay most of
you should not do your own thing because
your happiness and life will not come
from it it's gonna come from
relationships it's gonna come from
children it's gonna come from your
communities your hobby it's not gonna
come from work people are cheating on my
happiness is gonna come from work
because I am a demon from Hell sent here
to to to destroy and then to rebuild I'm
part of a cycle people don't get that
okay um
and those everyone that you sees who's
successful as a demon Megan Rapinoe is a
demon from hell she's a demon from hell
that Dyke worked so hard because she
doesn't seal the [ __ ] doesn't feel like
you feel she didn't care about the
sweater you got her for Christmas she
just wants to win Oh Megan grandma's
dying
oh [ __ ] her I want to play soccer I'm a
I'm a power-hungry Dyke that's all I
want I want to get in fights with Trump
cuz I can kick a ball my skills kicking
a ball in the net [ __ ] you but I respect
her because she's a demon from Hell okay
that's the real motivational training
Caravan you check it out goes who here's
a demon from hell many people aren't
gonna raise their hands because that's
good you all get jobs you all go and get
jobs but Amy Schumer go
yeah it's go ahead and he'll go yeah and
that's why she's an arenas now I'm not
saying you know don't come out of here
and be like well you know so it's so
donated money duh
yo Doctors Without Borders shut up shut
the [ __ ] it's not what I mean you know
what I mean when I'm
is the qualities that you have that make
you human if you want to succeed you got
to turn them down a little turn them
down turn the feelings down a bit yeah
turn them down gonna be more Asian the
Asian just business Asian succeed it'll
give [ __ ] hmm it'll flip out bagel shops
no manners is they just straight to the
point
they do what they need to do yeah so
what I'm saying is when I meet somebody
who's like uber emotional like you got
to rein it in or find a business where
you can be emotional but there's not a
lot of them a lot of business you know
to be strategic okay like my friends
think they're gonna all be entrepreneurs
but they can't not you know they don't
know what it's like to not like get AIDS
you know and I'm not saying that they
have AIDS but it's it's an accident that
they don't have AIDS so it's like you
don't even know how to not get AIDS
because you're so impulsive that you're
just like give me that bloody [ __ ] how
about you need to not do that you need
to get a [ __ ] figure something out
where you can like Megan Rapinoe dude
she's a demon from hell and I don't I
don't say demon from hell in like a
negative way I know there's a negative
connotation um but I mean this is a
[ __ ] that stuff their emotions stuff
Yoram your emotions are impoverishing
you they're making you poor they're
making you stupid not all of them and
there are people that are genuinely
[ __ ] don't message me and be like so
does this mean that a four year old we
can't know it no no I believe IIIi think
I'll probably vote for Bernie I think
I'll probably vote for Bernie because
Bernie's the only here's one reason he's
the only one not dancing with Jeffrey
Epstein at dinner
Bernie's the only [ __ ] not on a conga
line with Jeffery upstate for that
reason alone maybe let's try him right
he's in Vermont and anyway he wants
people have health insurance you know I
might get on that train he's the only
guy that seems like a person like I like
a honest enough person yeah I think we
give him a shot I understand why people
gave Trump a shot though like he's
the outsider he's not the out guys guys
guys guys
what outside is he you think anyone gave
a [ __ ] about you think he would care
about human trafficking he's on - he's a
more lago than like some of these girls
aren't of age he's like hey get out it
doesn't care you made him into some
moral crusader throw up throw up
why cause he'd [ __ ] say [ __ ] he
tweets and a Concha Cortez the other one
you like her cause she's a bartender who
can clap back brother [ __ ] up grow up
Gary Vaynerchuk you you you [ __ ]
don't deserve Gary Vaynerchuk he thinks
too highly of you that's the problem I
know what you are you don't get a
business you shut your mouth
I do understand when I go on these rants
why I think the dating podcasts are
successful because I do think after at a
certain period this is very toxic but I
do think like this is an abusive podcast
probably like people that some people
are in a relationship like an abusive
relationship with this show but all I'm
saying is that all I'm telling you all
to do is is be pragmatic and embrace a
cynical realism and just tone it down
you know stop stop being so easily
manipulated you don't all have to do
face app you don't have to do it you
don't have to do it the NSA loves that
you do it now you're only do you're
probably were in a database whatever but
you don't have to do it you don't have
to do what everyone else is doing I know
and they'll say like we're living in
fascism and then everybody the same day
does the same thing - ISM let me tell
you right now you people need an ism I
don't know what it is communism fascism
you [ __ ] out there need an ism and it
will take capitalism you need an ism you
need a boot to the neck most of you and
I don't know where it's coming from the
left to the right I'll just work for
whoever who's ever whoever wins the
battle I'll sit there like Grima
Wormtongue or salacious crumb because I
don't just well I don't want to be with
you I don't want to be at the masses
this is my new favorite thing you know
people go I love this time because the
gatekeepers are done and the people get
to choose no get the people out I have
no faith in the people I hated the
gatekeepers because they were also
people right get to people where's the
third option aren't the people on
tik-tok yeah
what people they're like oh the
gatekeepers are done no everything's
been democratized and the people can
rule the people can make the decisions
about the music the people don't
shouldn't have a say in anything really
every song that was a joke it's like a
cowboy booger and a booger book every
songs a [ __ ] junk yeah everything's
an ironic parodies an ironic parody of
something yep okay because who the
people that are so great
require nothing amazed they demand and
require nothing of culture and of their
government and they get it yeah and they
get it and they'll continue to get it
he'll continue to get it'll just keep
getting put worse and worse and people
want to talk about dating and avocados
and there'll be videos coming out where
Jeffrey Epstein and Bill Clinton they're
[ __ ] you know just [ __ ] you know
double-team in some [ __ ] child and
everyone will be like can we talk about
something else I want to tell you the
bachelor we don't deserve saving the
earth we don't deserve it you don't
deserve that you don't get it you don't
get it it's very hard to wrap up here in
a positive note because I feel a lot of
people I feel this is very positive to
me it is so positive to admit that we
are as a civilization we are hopeless
unless we merge with robots tech not
like III think that is such a freeing
idea that we as people have completely
failed it's not my idea it's not a new
idea
carlin a lot of people embrace that type
of idea
but I I just look around at the world
and all these people that are just happy
that well the gate the gatekeepers are
done now and now the people will have
their say
god help god help us god help us
bad babies a millionaire the president
is the guy that owned the Miss Universe
pageant that's the president bad babies
a millionaire and they're gonna make
their make it fast and furious 26
because the people get a say we're
living in idiocracy no thanks
get the people away no people maybe
that's the shirt we got to come up with
some merch shirts no people you think
your thoughts have no value that's good
um be more Asian be more Asian that's
gonna get it that's their they won't
work I'm a real I'm an RN and I don't
mean registered nurse you think that's
great I'm an RN and I don't mean
registered nurse you know what I'm
saying folks let's talk about better
help because you know people have said
to me hey this is a scam and while
you're promoting this here's a reality
folks I looked into this and it's an
online counseling service and apparently
they at one point said that they their
counselors were all licensed and then
they've kind of walked back on that
here's the thing with counseling most
counselors even if they are licensed are
stupid and counseling in general is not
hard it's not a hard thing to do I could
be a counselor and I'd be great so don't
if you need licensing if you didn't
better how it might not be for you but
it helps like kind of a risk it's a fun
little gamble you don't know who's
you're gonna talk to I like I think if
it's a dating site I jerk off while I
call I tell somebody my problem that I
just ease my middle finger into my
[ __ ] why talk to them I don't I'm not
hung up on people are like oh you're
pushing this [ __ ] product
ya know eat list
if you could afford real [ __ ] do that
but you should still do that if you're
if you're suicidal or really depressed
or anxious or whatever it is you gotta
get help in medication but if you're
just a guy that wants to [ __ ] around and
maybe hears some chick talk over the
phone go to better help maybe you're
kind of horny better help maybe just
want to talk to a friend who knows is on
the other side a better help you know
maybe you can get them to give you their
credit card number I'm not saying to do
that I'm saying that I don't i
everything can't be my fault folks you
know ah better helps a scam listen
listen listen
the whole counseling industry's a scam
counseling is fake psychiatry is real
psychology is real counseling the [ __ ]
does that mean they have all these drug
counselors they get a little counseling
certificate you know what they were
doing last year home invasions now this
year they're doing counseling last year
they had some gun in someone's mouth
while they were taking her jewelry then
they took a little you know two-week
class and now they're all the sudden
account lis-listen folks what are you
looking for out there go to better help
call them up maybe they'll help somebody
message me they're like better help was
actually good I don't know what to tell
you man I don't all I can do and all I
can say is that I believe that that
there are good people in the world and
if better help is enabling those people
to talk to each other for a price then
I'm I'm good with that but if you know
it isn't working for you or you don't
like it or it doesn't seem professional
enough for you then don't use it
supposedly they screen the hell out of
the people that are gonna be counselors
now you know folks I don't know it's
very hard people elect well if you don't
know why would you advertise it well
listen listen here's reality you
watch a TV show you know what the
advertised Denny's okay I saw a woman
once take a waffle Denny's put it in her
ass do I hold the television show
responsible for advertising Denny's know
I've seen people throw hashbrowns and
Pete the blood out of each other in the
Denny's okay do I hold two and a half
men responsible because Danny's ran an
ad there now no I had a a soup once at
Friday's it was a hair in it
I don't call up Oprah start screaming
hey there you advertised Friday's it was
hair in my French onion soup the [ __ ]
wrong with you [ __ ] so it just worked
for you then do it if it doesn't I don't
know what to tell you
but you know I'll probably stop the ads
soon when you find out a little more I
got a I got a C for this dis just sites
every story there's there's your side
and then the side that pays me money you
understand two sides there's your side
and then the side that writes a check so
I gotta listen to both I'm not if you're
listening this ad and your person you're
clearly you understand what I'm saying
here I don't know I think that it's
better than it was but I don't know I'm
doing a investigation I will not
advertise things on here that are scams
at least scams that haven't done a real
good job disguising themselves and I
think the problem that I have with this
company is they haven't disguised it
well enough and I that's sad because I
think I've known a lot of great people
it took a lotta you know made a lotta
you know you know they took a lot of
caution and care to really disguise what
they were doing she would you know they
would bang people over the head they
would even feel it
that's art yeah I don't know what's
going on better help don't yell at me
don't text me don't message me I people
have said it's helped them literally and
I'm not lying people DM me and said I
thought it's pretty good one guy DM me
it was probably someone to better help
had message me I don't know
[ __ ] better help is what I don't want
you don't message me when you problems
go to better I've go to better help and
sodomize yourself while you talk to the
counselor you know what I mean
I don't know better help.com is their
promo code yeah better help calm slash
Tim Dylan
like I said folks I'm just advertising
this yeah I'm not a part of this I don't
know what's going on over there
I can only I can only tell you that you
know you have to be a big boy or a big
girl and really use your if you have a
serious psychological condition you need
to go to an actual counselor but if you
just want to masturbate over the phone
and not get in trouble go to better help
calm slash Tim Miller thank you
nurse said all her friends on 8 Qian
what happened to HN then HN is back
where is the Donald the Donald has have
been taken off reddit so here's what I
think happened in the Donnell cuz the
Donald every now and then they get a
little perky in there and you know it's
throw out at a congressman's address and
go go see him you know you know maybe
they don't I think they do but uh I
think like you know supposedly during
the bin Laden raid which you know who
knows what really but the story of the
bin Laden raid is like either it was a
bomb or somebody walked in and they're
like we got him you knows about bin
Laden yeah I think red it was just
looking at the Donald trying to find
like a violation their Terms of Service
that was drastic enough to delete the
entire thing and I think like somebody
was probably just like I don't know what
they did but it might have been like you
know here's a photo of Nancy Pelosi's
kitchen from like you know and I think
cept like somebody from reddit like just
walked in the room was like we got him
and everyone knew that they meant to Bob
you know they're like we got him and I'm
like yeah the like yet they're coming
down and they pulled the Donald down um
Andrew Yanyan gang is does he have any
steam left I don't know I'm not sure I
just believe that I I know that people
say they listen to show they think that
I'm negative I'm not negative I am the
most positive human being you'll ever
meet in the sense that I believe you can
really do truly great things if you stop
like these old [ __ ] like whether it's
like these old systems in the way that
everybody it's just like guys enough of
this like the the how easily people are
manipulated by media we're in the blue
is a--they the mass media age is really
only existed from like what the 50s
until let you know what i mean like i
mean in the sense and now obviously in
the last five to ten years if the
digital media and things like that but
you look at how easy it is to just put
people and groups and how easy it is to
get that you know maybe it does turn
around maybe it does turn around
maybe maybe next year people are
throwing
French fries in each other and not
milkshakes I don't know maybe that's
step up but I think to look at the world
right now and to have like a positive
view of what's happening is is it should
almost be like you should be almost
committed you know what I mean like to
look at the world now a lot of people
disagree with me cuz these are people
that need to believe everything's fine
to get out of bed right you know that's
all garyvee thing it's the create your
own reality I'm like I can still
participate in this while admitting it's
got some cracks yeah I don't
are the people hopeful who are these
hopeful people there's they're out there
all the time because they need to be
because they're they're hopeful because
you're like hey man it's very La thing
negativity is just not my thing
it's not my thing yeah and then they get
hit by a car that has health insurance
Elena Bagon but up until that moment
we're all like chancing role in the
video game like doot-doot doot-doot
doot-doot doot-doot and the guy in front
he falls down the thing whoo but you
jump over it yeah so you jump over it
then you start saying hey [ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] the guy who fell in the hall that
was his fault [ __ ] him
he must have not manifested a positive
reality it's a very la thing he deserved
that yeah he deserved falling in that
hole Oh what his family doesn't have
food
get out of there would get me get out of
there let me meditate I want to take
some more time by myself I like
meditation all these comics it always I
love Nikki Glaser she's one of my
favorite people
she enough with the animals but all
these comics and it's not only hurts all
of them they love meditation they're
always worried about everybody but they
love meditation could you be doing less
for the planet while meditating how
about you go meditate some soup into a
bowl for a homeless person how about you
go meditate a house for someone I just
need to get myself in like a good space
so I can succeed and everything around
me can crumble and burn just admit it
just go admit that it's freeing mm-hmm
you can't that doesn't sell
doesn't sell and you Schumer can admit
died Scott you know talk about I'm
boycotting right you know Wendy's cuz
they don't what what did they not do I
don't know she got mad at Wendy's for
whatever they [ __ ] up her order
probably but I'm kidding shout out to
her lover for you you know I love you
[ __ ] never met her never met her I'm
kidding I met her watch me until her
Thomasson just did the Netflix 15 she
goes to Taylor she goes that was such a
great set you had and then she just
looked at major goes hello I love you
the high not you all night but that's
the whole thing people and I'm not
against listen meditate do whatever you
want but I just left idea that people
think meditations like they when you
hear them talk about it they act like
they are doing something for the planet
and now I understand like you being in a
good mental space is good for the planet
not being crazy is good for the planet I
understand that but it's relatively low
threshold of you know it's a very la
thing well it's just a very like I'm
just gonna take some time for me
self-care is the big thing now self-care
hey hey guys hey is there anyone in this
[ __ ] country that has not spent their
entire fat life caring for themselves
I'd like to meet them is there anyone in
this country that needs to be told to
take some time out for themselves I
don't think so
I've met nine people in this country
who've given a [ __ ] about anything and
the rest I mean it's just such a great
[ __ ] thing self-care
just take some time for yourself just
take some time for yourself you're not
treating yourself good you got a here to
care about yourself such a great there's
no other care you notice that there's no
movement for that no other care
self-care care about you what about
everyone else
it starts with you yeah it starts with
you when it ends with you it starts and
ends with you let's [ __ ] be honest
there's not there's not a epidemic in
this country of do-gooders passing out
because they're helping too many
people that's not an epidemic nobody's
going to the hospital because they're
dehydrated because they've just been
swinging a hammer building houses all
day for the homeless so what is
self-care again what is it masturbate on
your couch can someone explain to me
what it is even what are you supposed to
do don't work too hard
what self-care get toxic people out of
your life yeah take them all out of your
life why have people in your life have a
phone meditate in your room and get a
dog that you act like you want to [ __ ]
when you keep putting a Instagram people
know what I mean then weird with the
animals folks enough with that it's
getting enough with it starting to get
odd self-care could there be a more
useless I mean it's like telling people
this country to enjoy themselves you
know it's like hey guys take a look
enjoy yourself a country built on
all-you-can-eat buffets or bottomless
brunch being told to go out there and
let it out let it loose guys let loose a
country that's fueled by all-you-can-eat
dinner cruises booze cruises
all-inclusive resorts you like and
you're gonna tell these people just
relax self-care stop doing step doing
all that stuff you do for your community
stop working so hard on behalf of your
community oh you take some time for
yourself yeah we know from day one of
your life all we tell you to do is to
follow your dream only study the things
that excite you then we tell you to go
to a school for four years take out a
bunch of pretend money loans major in
whatever the hell you want and then only
get a job that really makes you hot and
wet you know get a nice job that makes
your [ __ ] wet or stiffens your [ __ ]
every morning and then spend all your
time on the way to the job and on the
way back from the job listening to
hucksters and motivational speakers that
try to advise you on how to be the
you and then only fall in love or
consider marrying somebody who checks
every box on an unrealistic crazy list
that you got okay and then have a bunch
of kids and just use them as status
symbols to one-up other people in your
shitty planned community but during that
whole life don't forget to take some
time out for yourself don't forget to
take some time out for you
tibula comedy comm I will be at
hilarities in Cleveland this weekend you
[ __ ] missed it already I will be we
gotta sell some tickets on the southern
leg of the tour okay I'm very excited
about this we're doing one night shows
down south it's gonna be [ __ ] bananas
everybody is gonna love it we're going
to Charlotte North Carolina comedies on
August 4th Nashville Tennessee August
6th Huntsville Alabama
August 7th Hoover Alabama August 8th
okay
comedies on Charlotte Janey's in
Nashville Huntsville stand up live star
dome in Hoover Alabama go get tickets
for those things August 1st through the
3rd I'm going to be at the American
comedy company in San Diego okay
so definitely check that out okay it's
gonna be really really awesome and good
night's comedy club late August in North
Carolina 822 August 22nd through the
24th good night's comedy club in Raleigh
North Carolina college might be back in
session so if you want to come and [ __ ]
me in the mouth in the greenroom send a
DM & a photo please Tim Jay Dylan di ll1
on Instagram were being shadowed band
our numbers are hurting please get over
there it's a lot of fun also Tim Jay
Dylan di llo in on Twitter Devin Costa
where can people find you you have a
podcast called hate that you love it
yeah it's on Apple pot yeah Apple
podcast what is your social media
twitter at Devon cost the dvan CEO sta
and youtube.com slash Devin Koster go
subscribe to Tim Dylan is going to hell
the YouTube channel please okay we want
to grow the subscriber
based there we've got clips coming
videos coming patreon will be started
within the next week or two we'll have
all of the archives from gas digital all
the shows that we've done for the last
two years a lot of great conspiracy
interviews if you're into that [ __ ] a
lot of funny interviews you can go back
two and a half years to see the start of
the show we'll have some different tiers
on patreon it won't be a ton it's not
going to be super complex but if you
want all those archives we'll get we'll
get you those archives we're also gonna
do an extra episode a week for people
that want to contribute to the show but
if you cannot afford that that's fine
keep telling people about the show
subscribe on Apple podcast subscribe on
YouTube weigh in if we should get a
studio if you like the porch if you like
the porch will stay with the porch for a
little while I like it you know I'm so
sick and I have to keep flying when it's
disgusting I should practice self-care
and not go to these gigs yeah usually
I'll be homeless yeah love that
self-care and I know that a million
people gonna get mad at me number one
they don't understand comedy so they're
gonna be like oh they're gonna be like
actually self-care is for your mental
health and it helps you stay mentally
fit and I listen don't don't start I
don't care
hey shut up out there yeah shut your
mouth what a Mac Miller's last best
songs was called self-care and then yeah
yeah he overdosed
Mac Miller who's very talented and I
like by the way he's great um I'm gonna
do some big social media stuff soon
we're gonna get I'm gonna get some of
these youtubers he's crazy wild YouTube
guys on oh really
yeah well those guys used to [ __ ] on
four years ago now we're all as comics
like we have to be them or we're gonna
die in the street that's funny how that
happened huh we all thought we was so
cool sitting at Gotham comedy club four
years ago [ __ ] on these youtubers
now they all own houses we can't afford
a chicken sandwich and we're desperate
that's what it's held to get on their
post Manning the Logan Paul yeah yeah
right it's true yeah it's the way the
world believed you leave your friends
and family leave them if they're not
doing if they're not working for you
take a sabbatical take a break rein it
in okay
you can you know I you know as some
garyvee fans message me like I don't
think you get it no I get it I get it
okay I get it okay everybody needs
something
some people need Gary Vee some people
need whatever yeah I get it
I'm not taking away what you if you need
it if you need Gary Vee to tell you the
hustle hey I don't you know do you think
Gary Vee maybe has some people on the
inside and Instagram and he was kind of
pissed off about
I don't know so I've heard things about
that I don't know I don't want to
embrace conspiracy thinking but I have
heard you're right why would you do that
I've heard that yeah I mean I don't know
I don't know I don't know man
I don't like people without a sense of
humor yeah you say whatever I don't I
don't care what you say about me I don't
give a [ __ ] I mean I think it's all fun
and games I some what I say has value
some what I say is insane and ridiculous
it should be entertaining but Gary if
he's not doesn't say that everything's
every word that comes out of his mouth
is great well he's he tweeted the other
day kindness is delicious I mean you
know if you need that if you're a person
out there and you need a guy to tweet
kindness is delicious
it's like this is l8 colt churches like
you know mosaic that church that la
Church all these good-looking people
just go in there and it's these [ __ ]
actors and [ __ ] they're all guilty
because they have money and all their
friends are you know living in their own
filth so they go into mosaic church and
you know they're electing this got like
a rock band on stage and they're like oh
whatever you rock and they're like it's
hip it's cool it doesn't matter you know
I love God I lead a trance for whatever
whatever it is you know I don't like
eight people serving the leadership over
there though neither would I they
wouldn't show up but Church was it was
it 11 but
uh you know it's a very that's tight but
they're not on the planet Earth here a
little bit no people are not on earth no
no and so things work really well when
they're not on earth layer like like
cult-like churches mm-hmm
you know horoscopes Horus I love I had a
woman that I worked with not show up to
work one time for a whole week it was a
weed job so you kind of could do that
right but I asked her like what happened
and we worked near the beach so on lunch
we'd go sit at the beach sometimes and
she said last week I let them be my
seagull it [ __ ] on my hand and it
already wasn't my month so I just took
that as a sign man and she didn't show
up to work yeah it was a maze already
wasn't my month she had a weird
interaction with a bird not by the way
no nothing is less interesting and I'm
not gonna go to it now nothing is less
interesting than like the burgeoning
weed business
oh no could anything be less interesting
the wasps like the word like I friends
in it and they try to like show me like
what they're doing Mad Men
it's like realize I'm at a convention
there's people blowing bongs it's like
guys
how about weari criminalize this and put
everyone in jail how about everybody
goes back to jail I'm all for that
banned private prisons we need prisons
inside a Starbucks and chase we need so
many prisons in this country that you
can't go walk a block without seeing one
yeah goodbye everyone